[Musique]
c'est une affaire qui rappelle
étrangement celle de samuel pâtit cet
enseignant assassiné pour avoir montré
des caricatures de charlie hebdo durant
son cours d'histoire rattrape en
banlieue parisienne une enseignante lab
a été obligé de quitter son académie
après un cours sur l'évolution cette
fois ci c'est une professeur de svt de
trappes dans les yvelines qui a été la
cible de lourdes menaces après avoir
utilisé l'image du chanteur soprano pour
illustrer un cours sur l'évolution de
l'espèce humaine en la case homo sapiens
elle glisse l'image du rapport soprano
l'enseignant qui a l'habitude d'utiliser
des personnalités pour rendre
l'apprentissage plus ludique n'y a eu
aucun mal contrairement à une de ses
élèves qui a dénoncé un acte raciste
vous avez vous un homme noir à côté d'un
singe votre cours et racistes sur les
réseaux sociaux le père de la jeune
fille a mené une vraie fatwa numérique
selon le procureur qui a condamné ce
parent d'élève à six mois de prison
ferme il a fait appel il était déjà
connu de la justice et de
l'établissement pour contester
régulièrement les notes donné à sa fille
face aux nombreuses menaces
l'enseignante a dû déménager quant à
elle alors soprano dans un cours de svt
comprenez vous que le professeur soit
accusé de racisme
merci elizabeth loewy d'être avec nous
directrice de la rédaction de causeur
merci d'être là alors je fais un petit
tour de table vous matthieu delormeau
vous dites oui bah oui je comprends que
ça que de racisme pourquoi
c'est pas chaud ça leur vie radical est
tellement choqué
je suis halluciné surtout éviter
l'évolution humaine je suis de ceux qui
ont écrit une photo de se prononcer mais
elle n'aurait pas encore sapiens a
condamné alors ces panneaux mais alors
elle a pris soprano comme alors comme
elle aurait pris vianney
je ne jamais mettre de nouveau genre de
la diversité donc il se trouve que la
bonté sont tous du sang c'est très bon
pour notre couleur de peau des 112 du
sage sur ma nuque et donc c'est soprano
qui va les lustres et
bénévoles illustre la femme de
l'évolution voyez à la femme l'évolution
il ya l'homme enfin mot sapiens sauf
qu'elle la musique et photo à côté voilà
à côté de ça j'ai passé de 7,7 pardon
mais maintenant on n'a pas le remettre
un noir c'est la galère alors je vais
vous dire moi je
pense que de penser comme ça c'est avoir
l'esprit tordu
s'est rassis cependant cette fois-ci
tous et surtout très dangereux où ils
excusez-moi ans à 400 professeurs de
racisme aujourd'hui vous blackrock est
une cible dans les bien sûr sur cette
dame a dû vendre son appartement dans
les yvelines le père qui a le père qui
l'avait accusé qui accessoirement trouve
que c'est pas bien d'enseigner la
théorie de l'évolution à tes enfants
parce que c'est contraire à ses
convictions religieuses s'ils voulaient
se perd et qui s'était battu contre des
policiers qui veut un contest en
permanence les notes de ses élèves la
rencontre est alors hissé battement
d'ailleurs excusé tout en mettant des
commentaires ensuite tout à fait
désobligeant mais s'est expliqué avec
elle à aucun moment cette dame au
contraire et de très bonnes volontés
pourquoi elle a fait ça parce que dans
son lycée précédent dans son collège
précédent nos services et une troisième
au blanc-mesnil des élèves y avait dit
madame pourquoi dans les cours on ne
montre jamais que des blancs donc qu'est
ce qu'elle fait à la fin de l'évolution
si vous voulez on commence effectivement
par le singe et puis on passe tout plat
toute la troupe est à la fin de
l'évolution yann ou alors est ce cas là
je pense monsieur je sais tout ce que tu
dessines
qui saura s'il te plaît s'est moqué sur
sopra nous parce que c'est le chanteur
le bébé enfermé
ces numéros 1 dès aujourd'hui dans le
journal de mickey la deux portes
tonalité la plus populaire c'est son
prénom c'est du moins tu as géraldine
non en fait moi je trouve que le
problème en fait c'est jamais cette
professeur mais c'est le papa kevin a
dit merci et elle utilise toujours dans
ses cours des photos à l'utiliser la
photo de ben apl utilisé la photo de
balasko a utilisé la photo soprano ça
d'ailleurs été une manière d'éduquer qui
a été validé par par sa direction dès
2018 donc pour moi il n'y a aucun
problème le vrai problème c'est le soir
et il sait les fatwas numérique c'est
que cette pauvre mana est là elle a dû
vendre son appart et elle peut plus
enseigner c'est les menaces de mort et
celle et l'on soutient pardon j'ai raté
la jurisprudence à nanjing fioles
l'éducation de la lorraine jean michel
blanquer faut lâcher un peu le pauvre il
a nommé un
régal je rigole je parle de son académie
l'accusation je parle de son
établissement parce que pour la protéger
en fait je vous rappelle quand même que
la justice a condamné le père à ces mois
de prison ferme et que
quel que s'est il passé les policiers
ont dit à cette dame vous n'êtes plus en
sécurité sadik en même temps qu'à
l'ambiance on est il ya aujourd'hui des
professeurs menacés dans ce pays sont en
alu ans qui a été décapité en pleine rue
quand vous dites cette dame est raciste
d'accord vous encourager les tumeurs on
est alors que les conséquences horribles
les amène en plus je vous regarde
guillaume gille j'aimerais voir
guillaume est évidemment que cette image
générale si
guillon si je suis désolé guy lafitte et
si cette femme est décapitée soda
c'est de
parler de ça mieux le patineur qui sait
pas encore où ça tient ou portable en
vol alors
léguer au bout par le raccourci qui sont
insupportables il faut poser problème à
la base si cette image est l'héritier
beaufort géraldine y aura des gens qui
vaquent se taper dessus et les
ratissages ou s'il vous plaît mettez
vous à la place des gens qui sont
victimes de racisme c'est facile quand
on s'appelle jean charles qu'on n'a
jamais été victime d'aucune
discrimination de dire non mais c'est
pas raciste mettez vous à la place de
ces gens moi je me mets à la place des
parents des cantons va comme mon fils
est à l'école et qu'on montre aux élèves
qui sont en phase d'apprentissage qu'en
fait mal et singes les noirs c'est un
peu pareil parce que c'est sale mais sa
merci
pasquale mais ça n'a rien
compris fort en gueule la belge stoppa
tous à l'image d'accor il croît de 6
voitures bien si on met dans cet ouvrage
passe comme si on est dans la même image
quelle qu'elle soit fait trop le dire un
noir et un singe par ailleurs dans le
paysage c'est raciste vous êtes
complètement d'action complètement dans
jardine malgré ration bien à la place de
soprano par exemple la photo de vianney
et que les promesses et que les élèves
dit madame je comprends pas ce genre
déjà qualifié le racisme n'existait pas
à me lever chaque homme sait jamais des
fois des gens qui aiment se moquer des
noirs en détenir un chien et la guinée
ont consenti à livrer contre les
pollutions nonce évolution de l'être
humain ne comptions pas du singe voilà à
ce fameux g et qui s'est dégagée madame
était en danger sur les terrains de foot
l'idée
c'est pas raciste
en
couple et ont désormais 10 d'ixelles il
dit que c'est maladroit
surtout du don mello
je pense que purement et simplement
cette fresque telle qu'elle est là et
raciste arrêts je ne dis pas que ces
professeurs l'est et surtout il faut la
protéger la défenderesse et regard à la
voulais j'ai tenté le casting non mais
laissez moi d'abord finiront bien sûr
non mais vous êtes deux pasionaria
complètement excité
en disant ça en lisant les légendes
détourner le sens du débat reprenons le
débat à la base vous avez un noir qui
est en train de prix story qu'un singe
bière sourit liste est une fresque et ça
c'est du racisme pur et simple a existé
séquences peuvent être pire mais ça
c'est honteux raymond j'ai pardonné
racisme d'abord d'une aile elle soit
raciste en enseignant à trappes en
élevant les enfants de ne pas dire
qu'elle ne peut pas penser qu'elles
soient racistes à prendre la dce et homo
sapiens et l'évolution alami soprano lui
même dans ses chansons dans sa chanson
ils ne connaissent pas lui même il dit
il nous parle de mozart de molière mais
ils nous connaissent pas nous on a du
hip hop plein les yeux on veut apprendre
avec des méthodes d'aujourd'hui hélas
elle fait cette comparaison la moi
j'aime ça ça me paraît pas choquant ce
qui est choquant c'est qu'un père de
famille ouais ça comme ça il lui
peut-être n'est pas capable de savoir et
ses enfants mais précisément les hakim
chanel comment les verts eelv une que le
bordel comme ça qui m'a tech la queue
non
médical et des menaces
juste à mort et nous sommes restés
calmes je ne dis pas qu'elle est raciste
extrêmement maladroit pourquoi les gros
raciste jonah hill et gros raté sur un
terrain de foot ils font des cris de
singe contient un blanc contient noir
contient nombre des grands raciste
assimile les sages à des noirs c'est ça
le racisme et l'image qu'elle a fait la
malheureuse moite extrêmement maladroite
pour des gamins qui regardent même
voilà gentil les
wallabies à marianne l'acier nord et
nice avaient
mis les part n'entend pas là mais
pourquoi il lève les yeux ça en fait on
me dit c'est pas grave si elle est
menacée de mort il avait réussi
géraldine c'est grave mais c'est un
autre débat
mettez de l'eau dans les territoires
perdus de la république ils peuvent
enseigner la sb tomber ce que les droits
de reproduction et de messages croyable
maquis drame mathieu ses valises avec la
vie vous confondez assimilés et
juxtaposés il se négocie à deux images
qui montrent deux stades de l'évolution
d'accord et moi je ne prends pas ses
enfants pour des crétins ils sont
parfaitement capables de comprendre cela
est d'accord que nous descendons tous
déjà m j'attendais je voudrais dire à
tweed cas paul andré julien louis un
tweet deux personnes qui disent c'est en
pensant comme guillaume et mathieu qu'on
est raciste moi je vois un être humain
par un noir bref voilà voilà bien de
votre récente du substrat y attrape
actuellement didier lemaire a dû quitter
son poste il ya un autre professeur de
philosophie qui est menacée d'accord il
ya sept professeurs qui a été exfiltré
par l'éducation nationale
elle a dû vendre son appartement elle
est maintenant dans une région dans
laquelle elle n'a aucune attache donc
excusez moi et ma rs vous devriez et
vous avez une responsabilité trop facile
c'est pas le
temps d'être pardonné alors maintenant
je vais essayer de vous le dire
calmement ce jeudi je ne crois pas du
tout que ce soit votre intention
simplement vous avez une responsabilité
vous parlez à des millions de gens à des
millions de jeux aussi d'accord quand
vous dites qu'en simplement vous dites
que cette professeur est raciste cela
excite des gens d'accord cela et quand
on vous dit que c'est une image racisme
cela donne des ailes à des dingues et
excusez moi on a quand même cette
expérience terrible de samuel pâtit
d'accord donc je veux dire qu'il faut
arrêter de prendre ces mômes pour des
crétins d'accord on leur met pas
effectivement on leur met soprano parce
qu'ils aiment soprano voilà pour les
intérêts des ailes d'ailleurs elles
adorent mais je le répète qu'il y est
parfaitement capable de comprendre aussi
bien que vous et moi que nous descendons
tous du singe cette fresque ne dit pas
autre chose que vous acceptez le monde
maladroit alors qu'est ce qu'elle a fait
maladroit
alors je te gens trouvent ça maladroit
ce que je trouve en revanche tout à fait
scandaleux c'est que des parents se
permette de balancer des trucs sur les
réseaux sociaux d'ailleurs il se trouve
que pour le coup le procureur a été
d'accord avec moi et la justice le juge
a été d'accord aussi puisqu'il a été
condamné n'empêche que la vraie
condamnation c'est elle qui la porte
combien de temps allons-nous accepter
que nos professeurs soient menacés c'est
ça qui devrait vous inquiéter ça nous
inquiète alors